حسنًا، آمل بالتأكيد أن تبذل الولايات المتحدة
وكل
قوة دولية مسؤولة كل ما في
وسعها لمنع التصعيد،
ويمكن أن نشهد حربًا إقليمية، وقد لا يسمح الله
بشيء أوسع نطاقًا،
إذا انجذب ليس حزب الله فحسب، بل
إيران أيضًا، إلى هذا الأمر لأي سبب من الأسباب.  أه لدينا
احتمال أن تستخدم إسرائيل
الأسلحة النووية لدينا احتمال أن
تنجر الولايات المتحدة مباشرة إلى
هذا الصراع، لذلك هناك
سيناريوهات مروعة غير محدودة وآمل وأدعو الله ألا
يحدث أي منها
وأعتقد أن التوغل البري الإسرائيلي
سيكون  يكون أحد الأشياء التي قد
تؤدي إلى مثل هذه السيناريوهات، وأنا متأكد من أن هذا هو السبب وراء
محاولة إدارة بايدن مطالبة الإسرائيليين
بالتفكير مليًا للغاية بشأن ذلك،
والسبب الآخر الذي قد
يجعلهم يخبرونهم بذلك هو أن لديهم
مطلقًا  لا فكرة عما
سيفعلونه بعد الغزو البري من سيدير
غزة أه ماذا سيفعل بـ
2.3 مليون شخص أصبحوا
معدمين بسبب هذا القصف الوحشي
الذي قتل 7000300 شخص حتى الآن ولو
كان كذلك
طلبت السلطة الفلسطينية التدخل، لقد
أجريت مقابلة مع رئيس الوزراء قبل بضعة
أيام وقال إننا لن ندخل إلى غزة
على ظهر دبابة إسرائيلية أه دعنا
قبل أن نصل إلى ما قد يحدث
بعد ذلك، من الصعب تحديد عدد القتلى خارج غزة
لف رأسك حولك وشاهد
مقاطع الفيديو للمباني المسطحة التي
طغت على المستشفيات صفوف من أكياس جثث
الرئيس الأمريكي على الرغم من التشكيك في
الأرقام
والإحصائيات التي أكره استخدام هذا المصطلح
لأننا نتحدث
هنا عن البشر هنا بالطبع المقدمة من
السلطة الفلسطينية التي تسيطر عليها حماس
هيئة الصحة ما رأيك في أه هذا
التعليق القادم قف مكتوفي الأيدي
ليس لديك أي فكرة أن الفلسطينيين
يقولون الحقيقة حول عدد
القتلى أنا متأكد من أن الأبرياء
قتلوا وهذا ثمن
شن حرب ليس لدي ثقة  في
العدد الذي يستخدمه الفلسطينيون،
ما رأيك في ذلك جيدًا؟
أعتقد أن هذا أمر حقير تمامًا.
قالت هيومن رايتس ووتش وسلطات أخرى، بما في ذلك الأمم المتحدة ووزارة الخارجية الأمريكية،
إنها تأخذ الأرقام الصادرة عن
الوزارة  الصحة وغزة بشكل
عام دقيق أم الوزارة
أصدرت أمس قائمة بالاسم والعمر والرقم التعريفي
لـ 7000 شخص
قتلوا حتى أول أمس أه
أعتقد أنه لو كان الرئيس عنده
أخلاق ممزقة لكان دخل
على  التلفزيون والاعتذار عن
تصريحاته، فهذا بالطبع يتماشى مع
خط هذه الإدارة التي هي
أكثر إسرائيلية من الإسرائيليين، أم
يبدو أحيانًا أن الرئيس
يقرأ من جهاز تلقين إسرائيلي في
تصريحاته، وأجد هذه الملاحظة على
وجه الخصوص
حقيرة